does it make sense that a boxer was
beating his wife and all she had was a
bruise on her lip think about it this
guy is trained to punch people if he
wanted to punch the woman wouldn't she
be knocked out and the other question I
have is what brought this anger out of
him if he allegedly punched her because
what women do a lot of the time is they
taunt a guy they hit him first and a lot
of times the the lit is from them trying
to get the woman away from them and a
lot of times their their abuse is from
the men trying to get the woman off of
them but
the officers I don't think handled the
situation accordingly but I'll tell you
why I think men have an innate instinct
to protect women and I think women know
this and use it against the men